this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Earth was shaped like a
donut
this is what mathematicians would call a
toroidal world or a Taurus planet
to me it's an earth shaped like a sweet
fried ring-shaped pastry
planets don't naturally form in the
shape of a donut but the laws of physics
do allow for such worlds to exist
it just wouldn't be Earth as you know it
it wouldn't kill anyone to evolve on a
donut-shaped earth
unless it had a shape more like a hula
hoop
having a center that's so much larger
than the physically solid portion of
Earth would result in some very unstable
conditions
see what I mean disastrous